an explosion inside a sheer mosque in
northern afghanistan has killed at least
30 people and wounded a hundred others
it happened in the strategic city of
kunduz close to the border with
tajikistan it comes just five days after
an explosion near a mosque in kabul
killed thirteen people a group
affiliated to isil claimed
responsibility let's speak now to
hashimahalabara he's in northern
afghanistan in the city of mazaru sharif
so with an explosion like this one fears
hashim usually
and tragically the casualty toll rises
quite quickly
indeed sammy and this explains the very
tough challenges i hate for the taliban
since the takeover of afghanistan now
eyewitnesses are talking about a suicide
bomber who managed to get in so in into
a packed a mosque pact with worshippers
and he detonated himself and this
explains the high number of casualties
and people are saying that expecting the
number of the death toll to further
climb later in the upcoming hours
because many of the injuries are in a
serious and critical
condition
is a crowded area in kunduz and the
mosque predominantly
is a
hazara mosque hondus is one of the
cities in the northern part of the of
the country where you have
different ethnic groups living together
the tajiks the uzbeks the bastions and
the the hazara now there's been no claim
of responsibility so far but the
the taliban spokesperson
said that
the taliban forces the elite
unit is there
ceiling of the whole area and trying to
figure out the circumstances of the uh
blas what happened exactly and who was
behind this but this is something which
is definitely going to put further
strains on the taliban because they came
to afghanistan saying that our biggest
assets asset is providing security
that
is now being
challenged by many groups operating in
the country
and hashim what do we know about this
group that's being described as a group
affiliated to isil that's claiming
responsibility
well what is happening is extraordinary
now sami in afghanistan
iskay or the islamic state of horashan
horace and is the modern time of
modern times name of
this region including afghanistan was
established in 2015 at the very height
of the islamic state in the levant and
it pledged allegiance to al-baghdadi and
then is said that its own goal is to
spread isil ideology in afghanistan and
then find itself on a collision course
with the taliban which was then vying
for a bigger presence in afghanistan i
was talking over the last few weeks here
in afghanistan particularly in the
capital kabul with senior taliban
officials about
about isuke and they said that they are
adamant they want to eradicate ice skate
because they consider it to be an enemy
an existential threat for the taliban so
from
2015 they've managed to
uh set up themselves in different parts
of the country
which is widely seen as their focal
point or the stronghold of ice k but
also in the capital kabul and also in
different parts of the northern part of
the country where i am now not far from
here there is a presence of different
groups i was planning a trip to
honduras but i was told a few hours ago
that it's i i really need to get a
clearance from the taliban to be able to
move forward to those areas because they
say that one of the biggest concerns is
that the presence of armed groups from
the road uh in different parts from here
all the way towards uh honduras ice
skate now presents itself as the biggest
challenge for the time
i'll be able to
clamp crack down on the ice gate we have
to wait and see because what is
happening now is that you have the
forces of the taliban stretched thin in
hondas for example
the taliban decided to move thousands of
these fighters all the way on the border
with tajikistan because of this tension
that has been
building up there and this gives us an
idea about the challenges that the
taliban will be facing in different
parts of the country
and that was
from mazzari sharif in afghanistan